في الحقيقه نقف على كومه من الحجاره
استحال هذا المنزل فعليا الى حجاره مفتته
صغيره كما يمكنكم المشاهده بعدما فجرته
قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي التي اقتحمت قريه عقربه جنوبي
مدينه نابلس في تحت استار الظلام الليله
الماضيه ودهمت عددا من المنازل من بينها
هذا المنزل وهو الطابق الثاني من عماره
مكونه من ثلاثه طوابق وفجرت المنزل بعد ان
اخلت العائله
والمنازل المجاوره وكذلك مسجد عمر بن
الخطاب هذا الذي يمكنكم رؤيته مقابل هذا
المنزل ومنعت الدخول الى المسجد كما
تشاهدون كافه ارجاء المنزل تم تدمير
لم يبقى هنا اي زاويه صالحه للعيش لم يبقى
فيه حجر على
حجر القوات الاسرائيليه داهمت هذه القريه
من محاور عده الليله
الماضيه واشتبكت مع الشبان الفلسطينيين
واطلقت قنابل الغاز المسيل للدموع وهو ما
ادى الى اصابه اكثر من 14 شابا فلسطينيا
بحالات
اختناق و علمنا ايضا ان قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي
منعت في الحقيقه منعت سيارات الاسعاف من
الاقتراب من بعض المواقع التي اصيب فيها
عدد من الشبان الفلسطينيين ايضا الاسير
بني عودي تتهمه السلطات الاسرائيليه بانه
نفذ عمليه في بلده حوار القريبه من هنا
قبل عده اشهر وادت الى الى مقتل
اسرائيليين اثنين وفي الحقيقه هو اعتقل في
مخيم جنين في عمليه مركبه ومعقده جدا كانت
بعد نحو 100 يوم من تنفيذ عمليه حواره
نفذها الجيش الاسرائيلي والاجهزه الامنيه
الاسرائيليه في المخيم وهذه العمليه ايضا
ادت الى استشهاد خمسه فلسطينيين واعتقال
الاسير بني فضل اذا هذا ما تبقى من المنزل
وقد علمت
عائله الاسير انهم ممنوعون من اعاده ترميم
هذا المنزل وبث الحياه فيه من جديد نشكرك
من منزل عائله الاسير الفلسطينيه اسامه
بني فضل في بلده عقربه جنوب نابلس مراسل
الجزيره محمد خيري